From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you heard our show last week, you know that we're doing something unusual for these two weeks. We're featuring stories about Guantánamo made by our colleagues at Serial. And the one this week is really the one that killed me when I first heard it. It's about some of the very last people still at Guantánamo, five men who were accused of plotting the 9/11 attacks, the stories about their trial.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你听了我们上周的节目，就会知道我们在接下来的两周里要进行一些不同寻常的操作。我们将播出由我们的《Serial》栏目同事制作的关于关塔那摩的报道。而这周的这一期，是我第一次听时就深感震撼的。它讲述了目前仍在关塔那摩的最后几个人，即五名被指控策划“9·11”袭击的男子，以及关于他们审判的故事。
And as Sarah Koenig points out, of everything that's happened at Guantánamo, the trial of these five men is the one place that you would think we could get to some kind of justice. And then, in this story, step by step and piece by piece, Sarah lays out why that seems so unlikely to happen. The fact that these men were tortured in CIA black sites for years messes up their cases in all kinds of ways. But that is just one of the problems in the cases.
正如萨拉·凯尼格指出的那样，在关塔那摩发生的所有事情中，这五人的审判是你认为我们能够获得某种正义的唯一途径。然而，在这个故事中，萨拉一步步、一点点地剖析了为什么这件事看起来如此难以实现。这些人多年来在中情局秘密监狱中遭受酷刑的事实，从各方面破坏了他们的案件。但这仅仅是这些案件中存在的问题之一。
And there's this one section of the story that I think is especially eye-opening, and that is the section where Sarah explains what's probably the best possible outcome we could hope for in these cases, and why, when that hits the news someday, if it ever happens, it's sure to be deeply misunderstood by lots of people, maybe by most people. And so with that, I turn things over to Serial host Sarah Koenig.
故事中有一段我认为特别发人深省，那就是萨拉解释了这些案件可能的最理想结果，以及为什么当这件事有朝一日见诸报端时（如果真的发生的话），它注定会被许多人，甚至大多数人深深误解。那么，接下来就把时间交给《Serial》的主持人萨拉·凯尼格。
Every couple of weeks, at the bland hour of 5:00 PM on a Tuesday, a group of people you've never heard of clicks into a Zoom meeting. They're all family members of people who died on September 11th.
每隔几周，在一个平淡的周二下午5点，一群你从未听说过的人会准时进入一场Zoom会议。他们都是在“9·11”事件中遇难者的家属。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 1: Hi.
你好。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 2: Hi, everyone.
大家好。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 3: Hi, everybody.
There's Colleen, a nurse practitioner in the Bronx, and Terry, a retired documentary filmmaker in Boston. Dianne, in Savannah, a retired ordained minister. Valerie, who used to work in nonprofits and her omnipresent feline.
有来自布朗克斯的执业护士科琳，还有波士顿的退休纪录片制片人特里。萨凡纳的退休授职牧师黛安。曾从事非营利组织工作、身边总带着猫的瓦莱丽。
Trying to get the cat's tail out of my face.
想把猫尾巴从我脸上挪开。
Barry, a graphic designer in Oregon.
俄勒冈州的平面设计师巴里。
Hey there.
嘿。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 3: Oh, Barry got a haircut.
哦，巴里理发了。
And Phyllis, in New York, a retired teacher, who recently turned 80.
还有纽约的菲利斯，一位最近刚满80岁的退休教师。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 4: You are not 80.
你才没有80岁。
I know. I'm not. I'm not.
我知道，我没有，我没有。
They've known each other a long time, many of them for a decade or more, through career changes and new grandchildren and health troubles.
他们相识已久，许多人认识了十年甚至更久，一起经历了职业变迁、新孙辈的出生和健康困扰。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 5: Well, well, well, yeah. What would we do without each other, huh?
好吧，好吧，好吧。没有彼此我们该怎么办呢，对吧？
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 6: Yeah.
是啊。
The first meeting I sat in on, June of 2022, I assumed they'd be like a support group. Instead, the topic that day was the physical and mental well-being of the five men accused of orchestrating the attacks that killed their relatives. If the men don't get the death penalty-- there's a very real possibility they won't-- what should the men's punishment be?
我参加的第一次会议是在2022年6月，我以为他们会像个互助小组。相反，那天讨论的话题是那五名被指控策划袭击杀害他们亲人的男子的身心健康。如果这些人没有被判死刑——而这非常有可能是真的——那么这些人该受什么样的惩罚呢？
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 7: I think we're hearing that the 9/11 defendants don't want to leave Guantánamo.
我想我们听到消息说“9·11”被告不想离开关塔那摩。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 8: No, because they think they're going to Florence, Colorado, which is very uncomfortable or worse compared to Guantánamo.
不，因为他们认为自己会被送往科罗拉多州的弗洛伦斯，相比关塔那摩，那里更糟糕或更不舒服。
Florence, Colorado, is the site of a federal supermax prison. Unless you're a federal crime buff, I'm guessing you might not be able to name anyone incarcerated in Florence, Colorado. These guys can.
科罗拉多州的弗洛伦斯是一座联邦最高戒备监狱的所在地。除非你是联邦犯罪狂热分子，否则我猜你可能说不出任何被关押在弗洛伦斯的人的名字。但这些人能。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 9: Moussaoui.
穆萨维。
Moussaoui, Hanssen, Zernoff.
穆萨维、汉森、泽诺夫。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 10: Kaczynski.
卡钦斯基。
Ted Kaczynski.
泰德·卡钦斯基。
That's Colleen. She tells the group she'd be fine with Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the alleged mastermind of 9/11, ending up in a place like Florence. She doesn't want him put to death or tortured, but solitary for the rest of his life would be OK with her. Valerie agrees. Others think Florence is too harsh.
那是科琳。她告诉小组成员，如果“9·11”主谋哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德最终被关进像弗洛伦斯那样的地方，她没意见。她不想让他被处死或遭受酷刑，但余生被单独监禁对她来说是可以接受的。瓦莱丽表示同意。其他人则认为弗洛伦斯太严酷了。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 11: It's awful. I think it's like being buried alive, in a sense. You know? You're underground 23 hours a day with the light on in your cell, and you get an hour outside if you behave. It's a really inhuman place.
太可怕了。我觉得那简直就像活埋。你知道吗？你每天有23小时待在地下，牢房里灯一直亮着，如果表现好，每天只能有一个小时在户外。那真是一个非人的地方。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 12: It's very, very strict, yeah.
确实非常、非常严格，没错。
Everything about this call seemed upside down, that this group of people would care about a humane future for the 9/11 defendants, that the defendants might want to remain at Guantánamo, that the last people you'd think should be dealing with any of this end up dealing with all of this.
这次通话中的一切似乎都颠倒了：这群受害者家属竟然关心“9·11”被告的人道未来；被告可能反而想留在关塔那摩；而本该最不需要处理这些事的人，最终却要处理所有这些问题。
And they weren't just doing a thought experiment here. Their positions matter. Of the many family groups that formed after 9/11, this is the only one closely monitoring the trial of the 9/11 accused, the only one whose members travel to every court session held for the case. Collectively, they've watched hundreds of hours of court proceedings, filed multiple amicus briefs. They research deeply, stake out common sense but often unpopular positions, and lobby aggressively for those positions.
他们不仅仅是在做思想实验。他们的立场很重要。在“9·11”后成立的众多家属团体中，这是唯一一个密切关注“9·11”被告审判的团体，也是唯一一个成员会前往该案件每一场法庭庭审的团体。他们总共观看了数百小时的庭审，提交了多份法庭之友陈述书。他们深入研究，坚持常识性但通常并不受欢迎的立场，并为这些立场积极游说。
This group is called September 11 Families for Peaceful Tomorrows, after a Martin Luther King, Jr. quote-- "Wars are poor chisels for carving out peaceful tomorrows." All the members are peaceniks. That's what brought the original members together in the first place-- their opposition to the US bombing campaign in Afghanistan a month after the September 11 attacks.
这个团体名为“为了和平明天的9·11家庭”，名字取自马丁·路德·金的一句名言——“战争是雕刻和平明天的拙劣凿子”。所有的成员都是和平主义者。这正是最初让成员们聚在一起的原因——他们反对在“9·11”袭击一个月后美国在阿富汗发起的轰炸行动。
And especially right then, spring of 2022, this group had some political juice. The 9/11 case was at a turning point. It had been in pre-trial hearings for 10 years already, 10 years, of waiting for someone to be held responsible for the deaths of their family members. And now a solution was maybe in sight. Peaceful Tomorrows had long pushed for this, for an ending.
尤其是在当时，2022年春季，该组织具有一定的政治影响力。“9·11”案件正处于转折点。它已经在审前听证阶段徘徊了10年，整整10年，一直在等待有人为他们亲人的死亡负责。现在，解决方案可能就在眼前。和平明天组织长期以来一直推动这一进程，推动一个终结。
Liz, one of the younger members, tells the group she's a little conflicted. She's always been for closing Guantánamo. It's been one of the group's steadfast positions-- close it. But then she visited the base again recently, took in the whole clattering machine of the case, and now she's not sure. Maybe it does make more sense for the 9/11 defendants to serve out their sentences at Guantánamo, to not close down the facility.
较年轻的成员之一利兹告诉大家，她有点矛盾。她一直主张关闭关塔那摩。这是该组织坚定不移的立场之一——关闭它。但最近她再次参观了基地，目睹了整个案件运作的嘈杂机器，现在她不确定了。也许让“9·11”被告在关塔那摩服完刑，不关闭该设施，反而更有道理。
It did make me question what closing it would mean and what all of this-- like, what's next? What's next for us? What's next for the detainees, the attorneys? And what does justice look like for us, but what does justice also look like for them?
这确实让我质疑关闭它意味着什么，以及所有这些——接下来会怎样？这对我们意味着什么？对被拘留者和律师来说意味着什么？对我们来说正义是什么样的，对他们来说正义又是什么样的？
Something that I never even thought that I would sit there and think about. Like, I never in my life thought I would be concerned about five people who were responsible for [LAUGHS] doing what they did. I never thought that that would happen.
我甚至从未想过我会坐在这里思考这些。就像，我这辈子从来没想过我会关心那五个负责（笑）做下那些事的人。我从来没想过会发生这种情况。
Liz was six years old when her father, a firefighter, was killed at the World Trade Center. And now here she was, 27, working as a city councilperson in her hometown, planning her wedding on the side, and on the side, side, trying to think through one of the most morally and legally complex criminal cases in American history.
利兹的父亲是一名消防员，在世界贸易中心遇难时她才六岁。现在她27岁，在家乡担任市议员，业余时间筹划自己的婚礼，并在业余时间的业余时间里，努力思考美国历史上在道德和法律上最复杂的刑事案件之一。
Most aspects of Guantánamo can fairly be described as perverse. To wit, we grabbed close to 800 men, flew them to Cuba, even though most of them were nobodies, low-level fighters at best. Some weren't our enemies at all, hadn't done anything against us. Many of them we treated with a level of brutality that would have been illegal on US soil. The vast majority, more than 95%, we never charged with a crime.
关塔那摩的大多数方面都可以公平地被描述为变态。也就是说，我们抓捕了近800人，把他们飞往古巴，尽管他们大多数人都是无名之辈，充其量只是低级战士。有些人根本不是我们的敌人，什么都没对我们做过。我们以一种在美国本土会被视为非法的方式残酷对待他们中的许多人。绝大多数人，超过95%，我们从未指控他们犯有任何罪行。
We'd shipped all these prisoners to Guantánamo without a solid plan for letting them back out. Many people sat there for two, three, five years, and some 12 years, 14 years, 16 years. We didn't know what to do with them.
我们把所有这些囚犯运往关塔那摩，却没有一个妥善释放他们的计划。许多人在那里坐了两年、三年、五年，甚至12年、14年、16年。我们不知道该拿他们怎么办。
30 men are still held at Guantánamo. Of those 30, half have been cleared for transfer, just sitting there. But the one thing that at least seemed logical about Guantánamo was the 9/11 trial. The idea of it was clear-- we held in our custody the men we believed were behind the attacks that killed nearly 3,000 people in the United States and kicked off two decades of war. If anyone was our enemy at Guantánamo, it was these men. If any justice was to be had, it was through this trial.
目前仍有30人被关在关塔那摩。在这30人中，有一半已获准转移，但仍被搁置在那里。但关塔那摩至少看起来合乎逻辑的一点是“9·11”审判。其理念很明确——我们关押着我们认为是导致美国近3000人死亡并引发二十年战争的袭击幕后主使。如果关塔那摩里有谁是我们的敌人，那就是这些人。如果有任何正义可言，那也将通过这场审判来实现。
But once I looked at it carefully, I had a "gather 'round, everyone" feeling. Gather 'round, and get a load of this. The 9/11 case, one of the most important cases in history, inspires a shocking question. Not how is it going to end, but will it end, ever?
但当我仔细审视它时，我有一种“大家都围过来”的感觉。围过来，看看这个。作为历史上最重要的案件之一，“9·11”案引发了一个令人震惊的问题：不是它将如何结束，而是它会结束吗，永远吗？
Colleen Kelly, the nurse practitioner, was my main guide for the 9/11 trial. So to explain it to you, I'm going to stick with her. Colleen's brother, Bill Kelly, died on September 11. He was 30 years old. He worked in finance, something e-trade. Colleen never fully understood.
执业护士科琳·凯利是我了解“9·11”审判的主要向导。所以为了向你解释，我将跟随她的视角。科琳的兄弟比尔·凯利在“9·11”事件中去世。他当时30岁。他在金融行业工作，从事电子交易方面，科琳从未完全弄明白。
But she used to visit his fancy Bloomberg office. He'd visit Colleen in the Bronx, play with his niece and nephews. On September 11th, Bill happened to be at the World Trade Center for a conference. So it took a few hours before the family figured out he was in the building.
但她曾经去过他那高级的彭博办公室。他也曾去布朗克斯看望科琳，和她的侄女侄子们玩耍。在“9·11”当天，比尔恰好在世贸中心参加会议。所以家人花了好几个小时才确认他在大楼里。
My parents, my mother in particular, had been calling me, like begging me to go to New York and look for Bill.
我的父母，特别是我的母亲，一直在打电话给我，恳求我去纽约寻找比尔。
Around midnight, Colleen headed into Manhattan with a friend to look for Bill, and they performed the same impotent itinerary of hundreds of other family members in the shell-shocked city, walking, walking, emergency room to emergency room.
午夜时分，科琳和朋友前往曼哈顿寻找比尔，他们执行了那个处在震惊之中的城市里数百个其他家属相同的无力行程，不断地走，一家急诊室又一家急诊室地找。
Colleen and her parents and her siblings populated a sudden demographic, which eventually would squeeze into a military acronym, VFMs, Victim Family Members. They'd eventually get their own section of the airplane that flies down to Guantánamo, their own escorts and drivers on the base, their own curtained off seating area inside the gallery of the military court, their own press conferences.
科琳和她的父母、兄弟姐妹突然进入了一个特定的群体，最终被缩写成一个军事术语，VFM，即受害者家属成员。他们最终会有自己乘坐前往关塔那摩飞机的舱区、基地内专属的护送人员和司机、军事法庭画廊内带帘幕的专属座位区，以及自己的新闻发布会。
All that was years away. In the moment, right after the attack, Colleen tried to find out what happened to her brother, not the general outlines. She had to know exactly what happened.
那都是多年后的事了。当时，在袭击刚发生后，科琳试图找出她哥哥究竟发生了什么，而不是泛泛的了解。她必须确切地知道发生了什么。
I became obsessed with understanding his last day. I want to know what my brother was thinking when he was trapped on the 106th floor. I want to understand, was he panicked? Was he OK? Was he hopeful? What was he thinking?
我变得痴迷于了解他最后的那一天。我想知道我哥哥被困在106楼时在想什么。我想理解，他恐慌了吗？他还好吗？他充满希望吗？他在想什么？
Like, it became very, very important to me. Like, give me everything. Give me everything right now. Like, I want to know everything. I don't know if Bill jumped. I believe he did. I became obsessed with that question in the fall of 2001.
就像，这对我来说变得非常、非常重要。就像，把一切都告诉我。现在就把一切都告诉我。我想要知道一切。我不知道比尔是否跳楼了。我相信他跳了。2001年秋天，我变得对这个问题非常着迷。
She went about answering that question methodically, like a detective. Several weeks after 9/11, Colleen's family found out that Bill had sent BlackBerry messages to his boss at Bloomberg after the plane hit the North Tower. The last message Colleen saw was from 9:23 AM. There was a whole hour to go. The North Tower didn't collapse until 10:28. Colleen fixated on that last hour, on Bill's last minutes.
她像侦探一样有条不紊地去回答这个问题。在“9·11”后几周，科琳的家人发现比尔在飞机撞击北塔后曾给他在彭博的领导发过黑莓信息。科琳看到的最后一条信息是上午9:23发的。离大楼倒塌还有一个小时。北塔直到10:28才倒塌。科琳盯着那最后一个小时，盯着比尔最后的几分钟。
Bloomberg also gave Colleen's family photos of Bill from that morning at Windows on the World. It turned out they'd hired a photographer for the event, who'd left just before the building was hit. Colleen spoke with the photographer, studied her pictures. In one of them, Bill's talking with a man Colleen didn't recognize, receding hairline, glasses.
彭博社也给了科琳的家人一些比尔那天上午在“世界之窗”的照片。结果他们为那次活动聘请了一位摄影师，他在大楼被撞前刚刚离开。科琳与那位摄影师交谈，研究了他的照片。其中一张里，比尔正与一个科琳不认识的男子交谈，那人发际线后移，戴着眼镜。
That spring, The New York Times published a big story, a tick-tock of the final 102 minutes of the towers. Colleen examined the grainy, zoomed-in shot of people teeming at the blown-out windows. In one of them, she thought she recognized Bill. So Colleen contacted that photographer, went to his studio in Lower Manhattan. He gave her an enlarged print to take home. She stared at it.
那年春天，《纽约时报》发表了一篇大型报道，详细记录了双子塔最后102分钟的情况。科琳仔细检查了那张颗粒感很强、放大的窗边人群照片。其中一张里，她认为认出了比尔。于是科琳联系了那位摄影师，去了他在曼哈顿下城的摄影棚。他给了一张放大照片让她带回家。她盯着看。
Yes, it looks like Bill, she thought. He's at an open window. She sees the back of his head. His arm is reaching across the vertical window frame, reaching out to another man, receding hairline, like the guy from the Bloomberg photo. Maybe Bill knew him. They're holding on to each other's arms. This photo is partly why Colleen thinks Bill jumped. Also, they never found any remains of her brother while other bodies were recovered from the 106th floor.
是的，那看起来像比尔，她想。他在一个敞开的窗户旁。她看到他的后脑勺。他的手臂伸过垂直的窗框，伸向另一个发际线后移的男人，就像彭博照片里那个人一样。也许比尔认识他。他们正紧紧抓着对方的手臂。这张照片是科琳认为比尔跳楼的部分原因。此外，人们从未找到她哥哥的遗体，而其他人却从106楼被找回了。
Eventually, Colleen was able, as she says, to let it let go. She realized excavating Bill's last minutes was her way of trying to take away some of the pain and fear her brother must have felt, a way to absorb it into herself, which was impossible.
最终，正如她所说，科琳能够放下它了。她意识到挖掘比尔最后时刻的细节，是她试图分担哥哥必经的痛苦和恐惧的方式，这是一种想把它吸收到自己身上的方式，但这是不可能的。
The energy Colleen put into tracking Bill's last hour, that ferocity for uncovering information and that fealty to facts, no matter how distressing, now multiply that 1,000 fold, and that's what Colleen has dedicated to the 9/11 trial. She's been to Guantánamo well over a dozen times.
科琳在追踪比尔最后那一小时所投入的精力，那种揭露真相的凶猛，以及无论多么令人心碎都对事实的忠诚，现在将它扩大1000倍，这就是科琳致力于“9·11”审判的动力。她去过关塔那摩十几次之多。
If she can't watch the trial in person, she'll sometimes go to a remote viewing station at Fort Hamilton, an Army base near the Verrazano Bridge in Brooklyn. When hearings aren't in session, which is most of the time, she calls up experts and attorneys to ask questions and talk strategy.
如果她不能亲临现场观看审判，她有时会去布鲁克林维拉札诺大桥附近汉密尔顿堡的一个远程观看点。当听证会不召开（大多数时间如此）时，她会致电专家和律师提问并讨论策略。
Before I knew better, I'd thought the actual trial of the 9/11 accused might not matter all that much to Colleen. Five men languishing at Guantánamo, imprisoned for 20 years already, unlikely to ever be free. Why would a trial affect Colleen's life? Her busy life, by the way. She set me straight. She did care.
在我不了解情况之前，我曾认为“9·11”被告的实际审判对科琳来说可能并不那么重要。五个人在关塔那摩备受煎熬，已经被监禁了20年，几乎不可能重获自由。审判怎么会影响科琳的生活呢？顺便说一句，她忙碌的生活。她纠正了我。她是真的很在意。
Oh, my God, yes. Yeah, yeah. Hugely. Because if Bill was killed on a street corner in Manhattan, where he lived, of course I would be at that trial every day when it came to a trial, you know? It's like, you want to know all the facts. You want to know how this happened, who this person was, what went on, and have people be held accountable.
哦，天哪，是的。当然，非常在意。因为如果比尔是在他居住的曼哈顿街角被杀的，那么当审判到来时，我当然会每天都去旁听，你懂吗？这就像，你想知道所有事实。你想知道这是怎么发生的，这个人是谁，发生了什么，并让人们被追究责任。
So, yes, I was always really, really interested, both in the trial as a form of accountability, but also what the hell happened that day? Like, this sounds ridiculous that I'm saying this to you right now, 22 years later. No one knows.
所以，是的，我一直非常、非常感兴趣，既将审判视为一种问责形式，也想知道那天到底发生了什么？这听起来很荒谬，22年后我竟然还会这么跟你说。没有人知道。
How did Khalid Sheikh Mohammed do what he did? How did the hijackers get their money? How did they get on planes? Who knew what, when, how? How are all these other guys, the other four men, how are they involved? So I'm intensely, obsessively, wanting to know how this all happened. And why?
哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德是怎么做到的？劫机者是怎么得到钱的？他们是怎么登上飞机的？谁在什么时候知道什么，怎么知道的？其他这些家伙，另外四个人，他们是怎么卷入的？所以我非常、痴迷地想知道这一切是怎么发生的。以及为什么？
Don't you feel like you know why they did it?
难道你感觉不出他们为什么要这么做吗？
No. I've been told by people who are not the five accused why they did it. No, I don't know why they did it.
不。我听过不是那五个被告的人告诉我的动机。不，我不知道他们为什么要这样做。
I see. You need to hear it from them.
我明白了。你需要从他们口中听到。
Yeah, it's just-- it's what I need. It's what I need.
是的，这只是——这是我所需要的。这是我所需要的。
Keep in mind, Colleen has looked at everything she can get her hands on about how and why 9/11 happened-- government reports, statements by the 9/11 accused, books by prominent journalists. Most extraordinary to me, she spent years visiting a former member of the militant group Weather Underground in prison. She wanted to know what it felt like when your belief system carried you past natural boundaries to extreme violence.
请记住，科琳已经查阅了她所能接触到的所有关于“9·11”发生经过和原因的资料——政府报告、被告的声明、著名记者的著作。最让我惊讶的是，她花了几年时间探望一名在狱中的前“地下气象员”激进组织成员。她想知道，当你的信仰体系将你推向超越自然界限的极端暴力时，那是一种什么样的感觉。
But none of it satisfied her. In this case, Colleen needs primary sources. She needs specific answers that are still locked inside these specific defendants. The trial would unlock them. That's what trials are for.
但没有一个能满足她。在这个案件中，科琳需要一手资料。她需要锁定在这些特定被告心中的具体答案。审判会解开它们。审判就是为了这个。
The military commissions at Guantánamo were supposed to be our Nuremberg trials, when the Allied powers prosecuted Nazis and German leaders immediately following the Second World War. The Nuremberg trials were huge, efficient, and by many measures, successful.
关塔那摩的军事委员会本应是我们的纽伦堡审判，即盟军在第二次世界大战后立即起诉纳粹和德国领导人的审判。纽伦堡审判规模宏大、高效，从多方面来看都是成功的。
They didn't fix the world, but they at least held racists and murderers to account, helped repair a broken continent, and reset a common morality that said war crimes, no matter how chaotic or horrific, would be adjudicated in a civilized court of law for all the world to see. It's no wonder, then, that photos of the Nuremberg trial hung on the wall at the prosecution offices of the military commissions.
它们并没有修补这个世界，但至少让种族主义者和谋杀者受到了应有的惩罚，帮助修复了一个破碎的大陆，并重塑了一种共同的道德观，即战争罪行，无论多么混乱或可怕，都将在文明的法庭上公开审理，供全世界观看。难怪，纽伦堡审判的照片挂在军事委员会起诉办公室的墙上。
Oh, whoa. What is that?
哦，天哪。那是什么？
On Colleen Kelly's wall hung a handmade primer explaining the military commissions, the opposite of the Nuremberg trials in terms of efficiency and success.
在科琳·凯利的墙上挂着一张手工制作的入门介绍，解释了军事委员会，在效率和成功方面，这与纽伦堡审判恰恰相反。
This is the weirdness. [LAUGHS]
这真是怪异。（笑）
Wait, what? Just explain what I'm looking at.
等等，什么？解释一下我在看什么。
Behind her bedroom door was a waterfall of paper, giant presentation-sized sheets describing the special court created to try a handful of Guantanamo prisoners we charged with terrorism or war crimes. The 9/11 case was meant to be the main event.
在她卧室门后是一叠像瀑布一样的文件，巨大的演示尺寸纸张，描述了这个为审判少数关塔那摩囚犯（我们指控他们犯有恐怖主义或战争罪）而设立的特殊法庭。“9·11”案件本应是重头戏。
This is really helpful because we all forget about the charges against the 9/11 accused.
这非常有帮助，因为我们都忘记了针对“9·11”被告的指控。
This document was for an explainer she did years ago. But Colleen was keeping it here because so much time had passed since the 9/11 criminal case started, she sometimes forgets the basics. Also, I suspect, because the case has emulsified into her waking life so that she hardly noticed that an enormous handwritten record of judicial disappointment occupied physical and mental real estate in her bedroom, spitting distance from her pillow while she slept.
这份文件是她几年前做的解释材料。但科琳把它留在这里是因为离“9·11”刑事案件开始已经过去太久了，她有时会忘记基本情况。此外，我怀疑，因为这个案件已经乳化进入了她的日常生活，以至于她几乎没注意到那份巨大的、手写的司法失望记录占据了她卧室的物理和精神空间，距离她睡觉的枕头仅一步之遥。
It's not good.
这并不好。
You can age it by the judge Colleen listed on one of the sheets, Judge Pohl. He lasted the first six years until 2018. Then came Judge Parella, who left after nine months. Then Judge Cohen came in, pledging continuity, so important in a case of this magnitude. Less than a year later, Cohen retired.
你可以根据科琳在一张纸上列出的法官来判断它的年龄，波尔法官。他干了前六年，直到2018年。然后是帕雷拉法官，他在九个月后离开。接着是科恩法官，他承诺保持连贯性，这在如此规模的案件中非常重要。不到一年后，科恩退休了。
Then Judge Watkins stepped in temporarily until Judge Keane came aboard. Judge Keane lasted two weeks. He had conflicts. Then Judge McCall, but McCall had been a judge for less than two years, which was against the rules. So Judge Watkins stepped in temporarily again.
然后沃特金斯法官临时介入，直到基恩法官上任。基恩法官只干了两周。他有冲突。然后是麦考尔法官，但麦考尔担任法官不到两年，这违反了规则。所以沃特金斯法官又临时介入。
Then Judge Acosta babysat the case for a minute until Judge McCall came back once he had two years' experience under his belt. Judge McCall is the current judge on the 9/11 case. He's announced he might or might not be retiring at the end of this year. I know you're not following this. That's the problem. No one can follow this.
接着阿科斯塔法官看管了这个案件一会儿，直到麦考尔法官在拥有两年经验后回来。麦考尔法官是目前“9·11”案的法官。他已经宣布他可能会也可能不会在今年年底退休。我知道你没跟上。这就是问题所在。没人能跟上。
Like, no joke, on January 1st, I saw some friends that I haven't seen in a long time, and they know that I'm very active in this work. And they asked what's going on. And I started to explain, and I see this is a guy who's a lawyer, and he's really smart and he's really engaged on issues of great importance around the globe. And I just see like, after a while, just glazes over. Yeah, I was kind of bummed out.
说真的，1月1日，我见到了一些很久没见的朋友，他们知道我在这项工作中非常活跃。他们问进展如何。我开始解释，我看到对方是一个律师，而且非常聪明，在全球重要议题上也非常投入。过了一会儿，我看到他的眼神变得空洞。是的，我有点沮丧。
Do you get this sense they don't believe you? Like, they think you must not understand what's happening because it can't be that bad? Or literally, it's just too complicated?
你有种他们不相信你的感觉吗？好像他们觉得你肯定没搞懂发生了什么，因为这不可能这么糟糕？或者字面上说，这太复杂了？
It's too complicated. It's too complicated. Because if you start to say something, you say a sentence, you realize you have to say another sentence to explain it. Because there's no way-- there is no elevator pitch for this.
这太复杂了。太复杂了。因为如果你开始说某事，说出一句话，你就会意识到你还得说另一句话来解释。因为没有办法——这根本没有电梯演讲（简短推介）版本。
No elevator pitch, OK. But how about we take the stairs, you and me, all the way to the top, and you lend me those-- I don't know-- seven minutes, and I'll spin you through this farkakte case and this farkakte court so you can understand the bind the 9/11 case is in right now.
没有电梯演讲，好吧。但要不这样，我们走楼梯，你和我，一直走上顶层，你给我那——不知道——七分钟时间，我带你梳理一下这个荒唐的案件和这个荒唐的法庭，这样你就能明白“9·11”案目前处于什么困境中。
After we captured the five defendants, the men we believed plotted and carried out the 9/11 attacks, we held them in CIA custody in black sites around the world, and we tortured them. After three, four years, we sent them to Guantánamo in September of 2006.
在我们抓获了五名被告（我们认为是策划并实施了“9·11”袭击的人）后，我们将他们关押在世界各地的中情局秘密监狱中，并对他们施以酷刑。三四年后，我们在2006年9月把他们送到了关塔那摩。
A couple of false starts later, the men eventually were arraigned in May of 2012 at a military commission in Guantánamo Bay. The five defendants were Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, Walid bin Attash, Ramzi bin al-Shibh, Ammar al-Baluchi, and Mustafa al-Hawsawi. In the courtroom, they would each sit in a different row, one behind the other, in the order they appear on the charge sheet, KSM to Hawsawi.
在几次错误的起步后，这几人最终于2012年5月在关塔那摩湾的一个军事委员会接受传讯。这五名被告是哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德、瓦利德·本·阿塔什、拉姆齐·比纳勒什布、阿马尔·阿勒巴卢奇和穆斯塔法·哈萨维。在法庭上，他们会按起诉书上出现的顺序（从KSM到哈萨维）依次坐在不同的排位上。
So, how is this court different from all other courts? And why doesn't it work? Any normal lawyer hearing what I'm about to lay out here is probably going to be horrified or else think I must be mistaken. I am not mistaken. Here we go.
那么，这个法庭与其他所有法庭有什么不同？为什么它行不通？任何一个听到我接下来要说的话的正常律师，恐怕都会感到震惊，或者认为我一定弄错了。我没弄错。我们开始吧。
In normal criminal court, a defendant has a constitutional right to confront his accuser. So if I accuse you of assault, say, I have to come to court, take an oath, and testify in front of a judge or jury. In the military commissions, they'll entertain a jacked-up form of hearsay evidence, which means an FBI agent can take the stand and say, years ago, I went to a police station in Yemen, and a Yemeni cop brought me some witnesses he had already interrogated. And I talked to all of them, and I wrote down what they told me.
在正常的刑事法庭上，被告拥有与控告者对质的宪法权利。所以如果我指控你袭击，假设，我必须出庭、宣誓，并在法官或陪审团面前作证。但在军事委员会中，他们会采纳一种夸张的传闻证据，这意味着联邦调查局探员可以走上证人席说：几年前，我去了也门的一个警察局，也门警察带给了我一些他已经审问过的证人。我和他们所有人都谈过，我记下了他们告诉我的一切。
But those original Yemeni witnesses don't have to be called in or take an oath or answer any questions because the agents who spoke with them don't even know how to find them anymore. The Yemenis' secondhand statements, made through an interpreter, mind you, can be allowed as evidence in the war court at Guantánamo.
但那些最初的也门证人不必被传唤、宣誓或回答任何问题，因为与他们交谈的探员甚至不知道如何再去找到他们。请注意，也门人通过翻译发表的二手陈述，可以作为关塔那摩战争法庭的证据。
And these aren't any old criminal cases. These are capital cases, death penalty cases. As one former military defense attorney said to me, allowing that kind of hearsay, quote, "that would happen nowhere else. That's absolutely insane," unquote.
而且这些并不是普通的刑事案件。这些是死刑案件。正如一位前军事辩护律师对我所说的，引用原话：“那种情况在其他任何地方都不会发生。这绝对是疯狂的。”
Also, torture. Statements derived from torture or cruel, inhumane, and degrading treatment cannot be used in federal court, period. But in the military commissions, it's mushier.
还有，酷刑。源自酷刑或残忍、不人道和有辱人格待遇的陈述在联邦法院是绝对不能使用的。但在军事委员会，情况比较模糊。
Something I said while I was being tortured, you can't use that in an actual trial, but it's still in dispute whether the government could use my torture-derived statements in pretrial hearings or use something my neighbor said about me while he was being tortured. And-- and this is the central issue now-- they might be able to use at trial statements I made after I was tortured.
我被酷刑折磨时所说的话，不能在实际审判中使用，但在审前听证会上政府是否能使用我因酷刑而得出的陈述，或者使用我的邻居在被酷刑时关于我所说的话，仍然存在争议。而且——这是现在的核心问题——他们可能被允许在审判中使用我在遭受酷刑后所做的陈述。
Also, all the classified stuff. It is mind-boggling the profusion and confusion over what is classified. In the military commissions, the accused isn't allowed to see all the evidence against him because classified, a ton of it.
还有，所有机密的东西。对于什么是机密的这种泛滥和混乱令人难以置信。在军事委员会中，被告不被允许看所有对他不利的证据，因为那是机密，有大量机密内容。
And it's not just documents the defense can't see. A large number of potential witnesses, people who worked in black sites, say, their identities are classified. The defense can't call them because they can't identify them. And if they do happen to know the name of a CIA employee, current or former, they aren't allowed to contact them directly.
而且不仅仅是辩方看不到文件。大量潜在证人，比如那些在秘密监狱工作的人，他们的身份是机密的。辩方无法传唤他们，因为他们无法确定其身份。即使他们碰巧知道中情局雇员（现任或前任）的名字，也不被允许直接联系他们。
So those are some of the baked-in problems. Now, to the weirder stuff. The cases, from the outset, have continuously fended off, let's call it, interference, intrusion, infiltration-- spying, basically.
这些就是一些根深蒂固的问题。现在，谈谈更奇怪的事情。这些案件从一开始就一直在抵御，让我们称之为，干扰、侵入、渗透——基本上就是间谍活动。
The first big incident that made the news was in 2013, just as the case was getting underway, the kill button incident. One Monday afternoon in court, a lawyer for Khalid Sheikh Mohammed was talking about evidence from CIA black sites. And when he said the word "secret," the CCTV feed from the courtroom cut off, meaning anyone watching from the spectators' gallery or remotely suddenly heard nothing. White noise filled the speakers.
新闻中报道的第一个重大事件是在2013年，就在案件刚开始时，发生了“关机键”事件。一个周一下午，在法庭上，哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德的一名律师正在谈论中情局秘密监狱的证据。当他说出“秘密”一词时，法庭的闭路电视转播中断了，这意味着任何从观众席观看或远程观看的人突然什么都听不见了。扩音器里充满了白噪音。
The judge and the security officer sitting to his right, they do have the ability to cut the feed to avoid classified spills. But in this instance, the judge hadn't pressed the button, and neither had the security officer. Someone else, some external body had cut the feed, and the judge didn't know who and he was pissed.
法官和坐在他右侧的安全官员确实有能力切断转播以避免机密外泄。但在这种情况下，法官没有按那个按钮，安全官员也没有。另一个人，某个外部机构切断了信号，法官不知道是谁，而且他非常愤怒。
All kinds of questions erupted then. Who was listening in? What else could they hear? Was this the CIA? Did the CIA just drown out information it didn't want anyone talking about? Who was in charge of this thing? Who was really in charge?
那时爆发了各种各样的问题。谁在监听？他们还能听到什么？这是中情局干的吗？中情局是否刚刚淹没了它不想让任何人谈论的信息？谁负责这件事？谁才是真正负责的人？
The kill button was only the beginning. In attorney-client meeting rooms, spaces that are supposed to be sacrosanct, they'd find hidden mics in the shape of phony smoke detectors, or else, hidden in the walls. The FBI would pry inside a defense team, in one instance, turning a defense staffer into an informant. An interpreter assigned to the defense seemed to have had a previous job at a CIA black site. So who is he really working for?
关机键只是开始。在律师与客户的会面室，本应是神圣不可侵犯的空间，他们会发现伪装成虚假烟雾探测器的隐藏麦克风，或者，藏在墙里。联邦调查局会潜入辩护团队，其中一次，将一名辩护团队人员变成了线人。一名分配给辩方的翻译似乎曾在中情局秘密监狱做过前职。那么他到底是为谁工作？
All this bugging and snooping, it was hard not to conclude, was an effort to undermine the cases, to keep evidence and documentation of what happened to the men in black sites from becoming public. This is what the CIA feared-- and still fears-- secrets of the torture program becoming public. The CIA didn't offer any comment about this when I contacted them.
所有这些窃听和窥探，很难不让人得出结论，这是为了破坏案件，防止秘密监狱发生的事情的证据和记录公之于众。这就是中情局所担心的——并且仍然担心的——酷刑计划的秘密被公开。当我联系中情局时，他们没有提供任何评论。
Torture has infected almost every aspect of the military commissions cases. It's why so much of the discovery is classified or not available at all. It's why the men's physical and mental health is a constant topic. It's why fighting over admissibility of evidence in the 9/11 case is epic. It's why delays and breakdowns in the proceedings are legion.
酷刑感染了军事委员会案件的几乎每一个方面。这就是为什么那么多披露内容是机密的或者根本无法获取。这就是为什么这些人的身心健康是一个持续的话题。这就是为什么关于“9·11”案中证据可采性的争论是史诗级的。这就是为什么诉讼程序中的延迟和崩溃层出不穷。
Every one of these problems-- the kill button, the hidden mics, the classification arguments, the medical issues, and countless, frequently ridiculous others that I do not have time in our journey here to name-- all of it has involved litigation that causes months or half a year or several years of delays. And that is how a case, which could have been-- I don't know about a slam dunk, but vastly easier, surely-- remember, KSM has admitted planning 9/11-- that this case is now entering its 13th year of pretrial hearings.
所有这些问题——关机键、隐藏麦克风、分类论证、医疗问题，以及无数我在这里没有时间一一列举的、经常荒谬的其他问题——所有这些都涉及导致数月或半年，甚至数年延迟的诉讼。这就是为什么一个案件，原本可能是——我不知道是否算是十拿九稳，但肯定要容易得多——记住，KSM已经承认策划了“9·11”——而这个案件现在进入了第13年的审前听证阶段。
Finally, last thing-- I promise-- appeals. Many, many legal experts who's looked at the 9/11 case agree that a verdict in this case cannot survive appeal, which likely, eventually, would end up in the Supreme Court. In a statement to lawmakers, a Marine Brigadier General who served as chief defense counsel for the commissions wrote that the myriad defects mean that, quote, "There are literally so many significant grounds for potential reversible error that it is impossible to list them all," unquote.
最后，最后一件事——我保证——上诉。许多研究过“9·11”案的法律专家一致认为，该案的裁决无法经受住上诉的考验，最终很可能最终会送达最高法院。在一份给立法者的声明中，一位担任委员会首席辩护律师的海军陆战队准将写道，无数的缺陷意味着，引用原话：“字面上有太多重大的潜在可逆错误理由，以至于不可能全部列出。”
And appeals, of course, take their own sweet time. The appeals could add another decade to this case, easily. So for family members of victims of the 9/11 attacks, watching the military commissions has been like trailing a mirage. You can hear their mounting disillusion in the VFM press conferences from Guantánamo over the years. At first, a lot of them, they thought it could work.
当然，上诉需要耗费他们自己的时间。上诉可能轻而易举地让这个案件再增加十年。所以对于“9·11”袭击受害者的家属来说，观看军事委员会的庭审就像是在追踪海市蜃楼。多年来，你可以从关塔那摩的VFM新闻发布会上听到他们日益增长的幻灭感。起初，他们中的许多人认为它能成功。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 13: I'm very honored to be here and see how our justice system works and the transparency. Because the world needs to see that.
我很荣幸来到这里，看看我们的司法系统是如何运作的，看看透明度。因为世界需要看到这一点。
That's from a press conference in 2012, when the 9/11 defendants were arraigned. Two years later, you hear people start losing their patience.
那是2012年“9·11”被告接受传讯时新闻发布会上的话。两年后，你听到人们开始失去耐心。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 14: If we could feel we were moving somehow forward towards a resolution--
如果我们能感觉到我们正在以某种方式向前迈进，达成决议——
This woman talked about how she'd been down in Guantánamo once before in 2009 and watched a mental competency hearing for one of the 9/11 defendants, Ramzi bin al-Shibh. Now, it was 2014 and she was back, watching a mental competency hearing for one of the 9/11 defendants, Ramzi bin al-Shibh.
这位女士谈到她曾在2009年去过一次关塔那摩，观看了“9·11”被告之一拉姆齐·比纳勒什布的精神能力听证会。现在，已经是2014年了，她又回来了，观看了“9·11”被告之一拉姆齐·比纳勒什布的精神能力听证会。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 14: But here we are standing in place, since 2009 to 2014, five years standing in place. And it's painful. But I see--
但我们现在正站在原地，从2009年到2014年，五年时间站在原地。这很痛苦。但我看到——
By 2017, you hear desperation.
到2017年，你听到了绝望。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 15: And I don't think this is going to be resolved in my lifetime. And that's really what I have to say. And it may sound negative, but I'm not negative with anybody here or any of the people here. It's just that I want justice done. And I can't see light at the end of the tunnel yet.
我不认为这件事能在我有生之年解决。这就是我真正要说的。这听起来可能很消极，但我对这里的任何人或任何事并没有消极情绪。我只是想要正义得到伸张。我还没看到隧道尽头的曙光。
After 2017, prosecutors stopped meeting with the media. For Peaceful Tomorrows members, Colleen told me 2017 was also the year they realized, oh, this is never going to work.
2017年后，检察官停止了与媒体会面。对于“和平明天”组织的成员来说，科琳告诉我2017年也是他们意识到“哦，这永远不会成功”的一年。
We've had it. Like, now we've had it. It's endless. There's always something, and there's always going to be something. That's when it's like, plea deals.
我们受够了。就像，现在我们受够了。这是没完没了的。总是有什么问题，而且总会出问题。那时我们就觉得，认罪协议。
Plea deals. The prosecution was still insisting they could get this trial done, get guilty verdicts against the 9/11 defendants. But Colleen and Terry and the group members had lost faith. They could see clearly now, the military commission system was a failure.
认罪协议。检察官当时仍然坚持他们可以完成审判，获得对“9·11”被告的有罪判决。但科琳、特里和该小组成员已经失去了信心。他们现在清楚地看到了，军事委员会制度是一个失败。
Forget about a trial. The only logical solution to ending this thing, to getting a conviction that would stick, to getting the answers they wanted-- plea deals. Anyone could see that plea deals were the way to go, right? That's after the break.
忘了审判吧。结束这一切、获得能立住脚的有罪判决、得到他们想要的答案的唯一逻辑解决方案就是——认罪协议。任何人都能看出来认罪协议是必由之路，对吧？休息后回来再说。
Indeed it is. Coming up, other 9/11 families and how they feel about negotiating a plea deal with the alleged 9/11 planners. Sarah Koenig comes back, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
确实如此。接下来，其他“9·11”遇难者家庭以及他们对与所谓的“9·11”策划者进行认罪谈判的看法。节目继续后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的萨拉·凯尼格将回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Forever Trial. We're playing the second of two stories that we're running from the new season of Serial, which is about Guantánamo. Sarah Koenig picks up where we left off before the break.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《永恒的审判》。我们正在播放我们从《Serial》新一季中挑选的两个故事中的第二个，关于关塔那摩。萨拉·凯尼格从休息前的中断处继续讲起。
The idea of a plea agreement was that if the government took the death penalty off the table, maybe the 9/11 defendants would plead guilty and give up their right to appeal. The case would be over. The plea would include an extensive, likely months-long, sentencing hearing, almost like its own trial.
认罪协议的想法是，如果政府将死刑从谈判桌上拿走，也许“9·11”被告会认罪并放弃上诉权。案件将会结束。认罪协议将包括一个广泛的、可能长达数月的量刑听证会，几乎就像它自己的审判一样。
And such a hearing would include a stipulation of fact. This was key to Colleen, a stipulation of fact, a narrative in which each defendant would explain, with precision, exactly what they had done to make 9/11 happen and exactly why they had done it. And that's how, through a plea deal, Colleen could get the answers she needed.
这样的听证会需要一份事实认定协议。这对科琳来说是关键，一份事实认定协议，一种叙述，每名被告都会精确地解释他们究竟做了什么导致了“9·11”，以及他们为什么这么做。这就是科琳通过认罪协议可能得到她所需答案的方式。
But a plea deal in the 9/11 case, for a lot of people, that's a tough sell. Because it's the 9/11 case. It's emotional, and a plea deal sounds wrong, like the government's giving up or just doesn't care anymore. And no death penalty for the people responsible for 9/11? Why would anyone ever make a deal with these guys?
但对许多人来说，“9·11”案的认罪协议是一个难以接受的提议。因为这是“9·11”案件。它充满情感，而认罪协议听起来不对劲，好像政府在放弃或不再关心了。而且不对导致“9·11”的人处以死刑？为什么会有人和这些人做交易？
That is an understandable response, especially if you have no idea how dysfunctional the court is. And let's face it, very few people have clocked the ins and outs of the 9/11 case, including most politicians. While President Trump was in office, a plea deal in the 9/11 case was a nonstarter.
这是一个可以理解的反应，特别是如果你不知道法庭有多失灵的话。说实话，很少有人关注“9·11”案的来龙去脉，包括大多数政客。当特朗普总统在任时，“9·11”案的认罪协议是完全不可能的。
Come 2021, though, a few remarkable things happened to shake up the military commissions. First, the long-serving and forceful chief prosecutor, a general who'd been committed to a death penalty trial, announced he was retiring. His replacement, Colleen thought, might be more amenable to a plea.
不过到了2021年，发生了一些显著的事情，动摇了军事委员会。首先，长期服务且强势的首席检察官（一位致力于死刑审判的将军）宣布他要退休了。科琳认为，他的继任者可能会对认罪协议更感兴趣。
Then came the sentencing hearing of Majid Khan. The military jurors' response to hearing Majid Khan talk about being tortured, their recommendation for clemency, offered a clue as to how the jurors might react to the torture of the 9/11 defendants, one of whom, as a result of being sodomized in CIA custody, has to sit on a cushioned chair in court, and eventually underwent rectal repair surgery. In other words, even if prosecutors got a conviction at trial, they might not get a death sentence.
接着是马吉德·汗的量刑听证会。当陪审员们听到马吉德·汗谈论遭受酷刑，以及他们建议减刑的反应时，提供了一个线索，即陪审员们可能会如何看待“9·11”被告遭受的酷刑。其中一名被告由于在中情局关押期间遭受鸡奸，必须坐在法庭的软垫椅子上，最终接受了直肠修复手术。换句话说，即使检察官在审判中获得定罪，他们也可能得不到死刑。
--watched in frustration as one judge after another has been replaced.
——看着一位又一位法官被替换而感到沮丧。
Soon after Majid Khan's sentencing, the Senate Judiciary Committee held a hearing, titled "Closing Guantánamo." The only victim family member who testified was Colleen. Her message was strong and sad. Family members who wanted and needed this trial to happen, she said, had already waited too long.
马吉德·汗量刑听证会后不久，参议院司法委员会举行了一场名为“关闭关塔那摩”的听证会。唯一作证的遇难者家属是科琳。她的信息强烈而悲伤。她说，那些想要并需要这场审判进行的家属，已经等得太久了。
In May of 2012, I sat with my dear friend Rita Lazar, watching the arraignment of the 9/11 accused. Rita's brother Abe died when he stayed behind to assist a disabled co-worker on the 27th floor of the North Tower. Rita is now deceased.
2012年5月，我和我亲爱的朋友丽塔·拉扎尔坐在一起，观看“9·11”被告的传讯。丽塔的哥哥艾比在北塔27楼协助一名残疾同事时遇难。丽塔现在已经去世了。
In 2017, I was on the plane to Guantánamo with Lee Hansen, the only 9/11 family member to be deposed in the pretrial hearings. Lee Hansen lost his son, his daughter-in-law, and his granddaughter on flight 175. Mr. Hansen is now deceased. In 2019, I was on a boat crossing Guantanamo Bay with Alice Hoagland, mother of flight 93 hero Mark Bingham. Alice Hoagland is now deceased.
2017年，我与李·汉森一起乘坐前往关塔那摩的飞机，他是唯一一位在审前听证会上作证的“9·11”受害者家属。李·汉森在175号航班上失去了儿子、儿媳和孙女。汉森先生现在已经去世了。2019年，我和艾丽斯·霍格兰一起乘坐渡船穿过关塔那摩湾，她是93号航班英雄马克·宾厄姆的母亲。艾丽斯·霍格兰现在已经去世了。
Colleen and her cohort had always been the hippie 9/11 group, anti-war, anti-violence, anti-Guantánamo. In the world of victims' family members, their views were squarely in the minority.
科琳和她的团队一直是嬉皮士式的“9·11”小组，反战、反暴力、反关塔那摩。在受害者家属的世界里，他们的观点绝对是少数派。
But now, two decades later, it seemed the national mood had shifted. Vengefulness had dimmed, and Colleen was invited to the table. Five other people testified as well, non-hippies, conservatives, a couple people who'd been Guantánamo boosters back in the day, who'd helped design detainee policy and the military commissions under President Bush. And now nobody was arguing. Plea deals-- it's the only way.
但现在，二十年后，国民情绪似乎发生了转变。复仇心理减弱了，科琳被邀请到了谈判桌前。另外五个人也作了证，他们不是嬉皮士，而是保守派，其中几个人在当年曾是关塔那摩的支持者，曾在布什总统任内帮助设计了被拘留者政策和军事委员会。现在没有人争论了。认罪协议——这是唯一的方法。
--Guantánamo Bay. I thank you again for your invitation and for your time and attention.
——关塔那摩湾。我再次感谢您的邀请，感谢您的时间和关注。
Thank you, general.
谢谢将军。
A few months after the Senate hearing in March of 2022, the newspaper announced prosecutors and defense attorneys were in talks. They were negotiating a plea deal in the 9/11 case-- finally. That same spring is when I started listening in on the Peaceful Tomorrows Zoom meetings. Colleen and the rest of the group knew a plea agreement and sentencing would take some time. One attorney on the case estimated 18 months.
2022年3月参议院听证会几个月后，报纸宣布检察官和辩护律师正在商谈。他们终于在“9·11”案中进行认罪谈判了。那年春天，我开始监听“和平明天”的Zoom会议。科琳和小组其他人知道认罪协议和量刑需要一些时间。案件的一名律师估计需要18个月。
Their strategy was to stay cool, which the lawyers negotiating the deal had also recommended. Yes, the plea talks had been in the papers. The news was out there. But still, they decided, let's not make a lot of noise, no big public push. The risk of riling up opposition was too great. This thing was so fragile politically, even minor blowback could snuff it out. So, they'd lie low.
他们的策略是保持冷静，谈判协议的律师也建议这样做。是的，认罪谈判已经在报纸上登出来了。消息已经传出去了。但他们仍然决定，不要制造太大的声势，不要进行大规模的公开推动。激怒反对者的风险太大了。这件事在政治上太脆弱了，即使是轻微的阻力也可能扼杀它。所以，他们保持低调。
The meetings, though, were animated. The group worked on a list of questions they wanted the defendants to answer in the event of a sentencing, questions some of them have harbored since 2001.
不过，会议气氛很热烈。该小组制定了一份他们希望被告在量刑时回答的问题清单，有些问题是他们自2001年以来一直心存疑虑的。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 16: Who knew that there were 20 hijackers and how they were getting their tickets?
谁知道有20名劫机者，他们是怎么拿到票的？
They want to know, who was the financial mastermind? Was it KSM's nephew, Ammar al-Baluchi?
他们想知道，谁是金融主谋？是KSM的侄子阿马尔·阿勒巴卢奇吗？
Did he communicate to so-and-so that he was making this transaction? Is that maybe what you're more after?
他是否传达给某人他正在进行这笔交易？这难道是你更想知道的吗？
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 16: And what were they told about why the transaction was made?
他们被告知关于为什么进行这笔交易的信息是什么？
The finances are a big topic with this group, not only because they want to understand the inner workings of the plot, but because they want to understand the relative guilt of the five defendants. Is Ammar al-Baluchi less culpable than his uncle, Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, but more culpable than Mustafa al-Hawsawi? They passed their questions along to a defense attorney working on the 9/11 case, a defense attorney.
财务是该小组的一个重大议题，不仅因为他们想了解阴谋的内部运作，还因为他们想了解五名被告的相对罪责。阿马尔·阿勒巴卢奇比他的叔叔哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德罪责轻吗，但比穆斯塔法·哈萨维罪责重吗？他们把问题传给了“9·11”案的一名辩护律师，一名辩护律师。
At first, this surprised me, but they were talking to defense attorneys as much, if not more, than they were talking to prosecutors. And then, they waited. Six months passed. Eight months. By December, nine months since the plea negotiations started. Everyone was getting antsy.
起初，这让我很惊讶，但他们与辩护律师的交谈次数即使不比与检察官的交谈次数多，也至少一样多。然后，他们等待着。六个月过去了。八个月。到12月，认罪谈判已经进行了九个月。每个人都变得不安起来。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 16: So I just-- boy, this is beyond any kind of advocacy I've ever done before.
所以我只是——天哪，这超出了我以前做过的任何倡导工作。
Hearings in the 9/11 case were on hold while the prosecution and defense tried to work it out. They were supposed to agree on so-called policy principles by now, which is a dry term, but it was the meat of the deal. If the men pleaded guilty, what would they get in return?
在检察官和辩方试图达成协议时，“9·11”案的听证会处于暂停状态。他们本应在此前商定所谓的政策原则，这是一个枯燥的术语，但这是交易的核心内容。如果这些人认罪，他们会得到什么回报？
The policy principles mostly had to do with the conditions of the men's imprisonment. They wanted assurances that as long as they were in prison, they'd have a communal situation, like they have now-- the ability to eat together and pray together, no solitary confinement. Also, they wanted proper, sustained treatment for their physical and psychological trauma caused by the torture, and the ability to communicate better with their families.
政策原则主要与这些人的监禁条件有关。他们想要保证，只要他们被监禁，他们就会有像现在这样的公共环境——能够一起吃饭、一起祈祷，没有单独监禁。此外，他们还想要对酷刑造成的身体和心理创伤进行适当、持续的治疗，并改善与家人的沟通能力。
For the plea to progress, the prosecution needed an answer from the Biden administration, whether they supported the policy principles. But Biden wasn't saying anything at all.
为了让认罪谈判取得进展，检方需要得到拜登政府的答复，即他们是否支持这些政策原则。但拜登什么也没说。
The one-year mark came and went. Now, it was March of 2023. Still nothing. Valerie's cat was dying.
一周年过去了。现在是2023年3月。仍然没有动静。瓦莱丽的猫快死了。
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER 17: I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
When you pet him, you have to be so careful because he's all bones, you know?
当你抚摸它时，你必须非常小心，因为它只剩下骨头了，你知道吗？
Liz's wedding was off. She was now running for mayor. Phyllis suggested maybe they take a breather, get some distance from all the discouragement. J. Connell, a defense attorney, came to a meeting to give an update, which was no update on the deal, really, but he did have something to tell them.
利兹的婚礼取消了。她现在正在竞选市长。菲利斯建议他们也许该休息一下，和所有令人沮丧的事情保持一点距离。辩护律师J.康奈尔来到会议上给出一个更新，其实关于协议并没有什么更新，但他确实有话要告诉他们。
So I have now seen a draft of the proposed stipulation of facts, and it is extensive. It is 200 pages long.
我现在已经看过了拟议的事实认定协议草案，它是详尽的。足足200页。
That's the document Colleen and the others are waiting for, the main thing they want from this plea. In the 200-page statement, J.'s client, Aamar al-Baluchi, had laid out his background, how he ended up in this situation at such a young age. Then he talks about 9/11.
这就是科琳和其他人正在等待的文件，这是他们想从这个认罪协议中得到的主要东西。在那份200页的陈述中，J.的客户阿马尔·阿勒巴卢奇详细说明了他的背景，他是如何以如此年轻的年纪陷入这种境地的。然后他谈到了“9·11”。
It's really a deep examination of who exactly did what in the plot around 9/11. I mean, it's very detailed on that point.
这确实是对“9·11”阴谋中究竟是谁做了什么的深入调查。我是说，关于这一点非常详细。
Finally, there's a section about what happened to him in prison.
最后，有一个关于他在监狱中遭遇的部分。
So, this 200-page document really dives deep into, I think, basically any question that anyone would have.
所以，这份200页的文件确实深入探讨了，我认为，基本上任何人会有的任何问题。
Liz has a "holy shit" look on her face. Later, she told me that's what she was feeling. Holy shit. This information is out there. And why do we not have it? One of the five defendants had answered their questions in a document they couldn't see-- not yet, not unless there was a plea. But it was something.
利兹脸上有一种“天哪”的表情。后来，她告诉我那是她的感受。天哪。这些信息确实存在。为什么我们没有呢？五名被告中的一人在一份他们看不到的文件中回答了他们的问题——如果不是认罪，他们就看不到。但这总算是个东西。
And then, August of last year, the public suddenly woke up. It was the government who woke them, not peaceful tomorrows. The prosecution sent a letter to 9/11 victim family members, to a much wider group than usual, some of whom hadn't been contacted about this case in forever, letting them know the plea negotiations were happening and seeking their opinions or concerns. And oh, man, did they need an editor for this letter-- robotically matter of fact, lousy with acronyms.
然后，去年8月，公众突然醒悟了。是政府唤醒了他们，而不是“和平明天”。检方致信“9·11”受害者家属，范围比平时广得多，有些人已经很久没有被联系过关于这个案件的事了，通知他们认罪谈判正在进行，并寻求他们的意见或担忧。天哪，他们真的需要给这封信配个编辑——机器般的陈述，充斥着缩略词。
Sure enough, nearly a year and a half after the plea negotiations had first been reported, a whole new crop of people did have opinions and concerns. They called the prosecution office. They called the press. They called Capitol Hill. The AP ran a story. Plea negotiations could mean no 9/11 defendants face the death penalty, the US tells families. Conservatives made immediate hay. Ted Cruz took to his podcast.
果然，在认罪谈判首次报道近一年半后，一群全新的人确实有了意见和担忧。他们致电起诉办公室。他们致电媒体。他们致电国会山。美联社发表了一篇报道。美联社称：“认罪谈判可能意味着没有‘9·11’被告面临死刑。”保守派立即大做文章。泰德·克鲁兹在他的播客上发表评论。
This story is absolutely outrageous. And I think everyone hearing it should be shocked and should be furious.
这个故事简直令人愤慨。我认为每个听到它的人都应该感到震惊，都应该感到愤怒。
Family members expressed outrage on TV.
家属们在电视上表达了愤怒。
I feel like the Biden administration should order them not to accept this plea deal.
我觉得拜登政府应该命令他们不要接受这个认罪协议。
More than 2,000 victim family members wrote an open letter to the president, protesting the plea deal. Peaceful Tomorrows members were feeling like, ugh, if they could just gather all the family members in the same room and explain everything they knew about how broken the military commissions were, maybe the others would see they were never going to get a trial or the death penalty. If they wanted answers or any shred of accountability, a plea deal was the best they could hope for.
超过2000名遇难者家属写了一封给总统的公开信，抗议认罪协议。“和平明天”的成员们感觉像，呃，如果他们能把所有家属聚在一个房间里，向他们解释他们所知道的关于军事委员会是多么破碎的一切，也许其他人会看到他们永远不会得到审判或死刑。如果他们想要答案或任何一点问责，认罪协议是他们能希望得到的最好的结果。
Within a couple of weeks, President Biden broke his silence regarding the plea deals. Well, he never said anything publicly, but a line in a prosecution court filing said the Biden administration declined the so-called policy principles. Biden was not on board. He would not support an assurance of no solitary confinement or an assurance of torture rehabilitation.
几周内，拜登总统打破了他在认罪协议问题上的沉默。嗯，他从未公开发表任何言论，但在检方向法庭提交的文件中有一行字，称拜登政府拒绝了所谓的政策原则。拜登不支持。他不会支持单独监禁的保证或酷刑康复的保证。
For the past year and a half, no one had seemed clear on what role the White House was playing in these unprecedented plea negotiations, in this unprecedented criminal case, in this unprecedented court. Maybe the president really disagreed with the terms of the deal, or maybe, in September of 2023, it just came down to realpolitik.
过去一年半里，没有人搞清楚白宫在这个前所未有的认罪谈判中、在这个前所未有的刑事案件中、在这个前所未有的法庭中扮演什么角色。也许总统真的不同意协议条款，或者，也许在2023年9月，这只是归结为现实政治。
He's coming up on an election. And perhaps the mother of all bad Guantánamo headlines is the one that says you're negotiating sleeping arrangements and therapy with Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, the man who claimed to have beheaded Daniel Pearl and orchestrated the most devastating terror attack in modern history. So.
他即将面临选举。而关塔那摩最糟糕的头条新闻莫过于说你正在和哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德商量睡眠安排和心理治疗，这个人自称斩首了丹尼尔·珀尔，策划了现代史上最具毁灭性的恐怖袭击。所以。
I kept thinking about Colleen. How on Earth did she have the stamina for this? I would have given up years ago, probably a decade ago, found some way to talk myself out of caring anymore. I'd asked her, was that the hardest part, just staying with it?
我一直想着科琳。她究竟哪来的体力承受这些？如果是我，早在几年前，可能十年前就会放弃，找到某种方式说服自己不再关心了。我问过她，最困难的部分是不是仅仅是坚持下去？
No.
不。
No?
不？
Because I'm so stubborn. Seriously. Being stubborn. Like, I am not going to let their failure be mine as well. I am sticking with this. I'm not giving up until this ends some way, somehow. I'm not. I'm not giving up.
因为我太固执了。说真的。就是固执。就像，我不会让他们的失败也成为我的失败。我坚持这一原则。我不放弃，直到这件事以某种方式、某种途径结束。我不会。我不会放弃。
And so Colleen headed down to Guantánamo. Because of the plea negotiations, and before that, COVID, the 9/11 case hadn't seen much court action since 2019. Now, September of 2023, the whole enterprise cranked back up again. For the 9/11 case, that's five teams of roughly 20 people per team-- lawyers and interpreters and analysts-- then the judge and his staff, plus observers and reporters and their minders and escorts. Maybe 150 people heaving themselves to Cuba, including Colleen.
于是科琳前往关塔那摩。由于认罪谈判，再加上在此之前的疫情，自2019年以来，“9·11”案几乎没有太多的法庭活动。现在，2023年9月，整个企业又重新开动了。对于“9·11”案，这意味着五个团队，每个团队大约20人——律师、翻译和分析师——然后是法官和他的工作人员，加上观察员、记者以及他们的监护人和护送人员。可能有150人涌向古巴，包括科琳。
I traveled alongside Colleen. She hadn't been to Guantánamo for 3 and 1/2 years. She was in a brighter mood than I expected At the hotel, she joked that the complimentary laundry pods in her room might be listening devices.
我与科琳同行。她已经有三年半没去过关塔那摩了。她的心情比我预期的要好。在酒店里，她开玩笑说房间里的免费洗衣球可能是窃听装置。
Maybe that's a secret listening device.
也许那是个秘密窃听装置。
[LAUGHS] That would be really funny.
（笑）那会很有趣。
It would be. All thrown in the washer, and that's what activates it to send the--
会有的。全部扔进洗衣机，那就是触发它发送信号的原因——
I didn't see Colleen all that much during the week. At Guantánamo, the VFMs are closely guarded and protected, mostly in an effort to keep media away from them. So it felt almost illegal to seek her out. In the courtroom gallery, we'd nod to each other self-consciously as I walked by the VFM section to get to my seat.
那周我没怎么见到科琳。在关塔那摩，VFM受到严密监视和保护，主要是为了让媒体远离他们。所以试图找到她感觉几乎是非法的。在法庭画廊里，当我走过VFM区去座位时，我们会自知理亏地向对方点头。
It was a strange split-screen experience to watch this pretrial hearing, knowing, or at least strongly believing, none of this is leading to an actual verdict. But also, it's court. So it's interesting, people arguing passionately about secrecy and the Constitution, witnesses testifying nervously or testily. Within the larger narrative of inaction, there's a lot of action.
观看这次审前听证会是一种奇怪的分屏体验，知道，或者至少强烈认为，这一切都不会导致实际的裁决。但同时，它毕竟是法庭。所以很有意思，人们在热烈地争论机密和宪法，证人紧张或暴躁地作证。在更大的不作为叙事中，有很多行动。
This week's hearing, they were dealing with the crux of the case, whether statements the defendants made in 2007 after they got to Guantánamo and were no longer in CIA custody, whether those statements could be used as evidence at trial. The statements, which are critical to the prosecution, are known as the "clean team statements," since they were taken by teams of government investigators who were not CIA and were not, the government argues, using any form of coercion.
这周的听证会，他们正在处理案件的核心，即被告在2007年到达关塔那摩并不再受中情局拘留后所做的陈述，是否可以作为审判证据使用。这些陈述对检方至关重要，被称为“清洁团队陈述”，因为它们是由政府调查团队采集的，他们不是中情局成员，而且据政府辩称，没有使用任何形式的强制手段。
The defense wants the clean team statements thrown out, arguing, among other reasons, that they are tainted, a backdoor way for torture-derived evidence to enter the trial, and that the interviews were not truly voluntary. Not to mention that the men were never sufficiently informed of their rights in these interviews or allowed a lawyer.
辩方希望排除这些“清洁团队陈述”，辩称除此之外的原因，它们是受污染的，是酷刑得出的证据进入审判的后门，且采访并非真正自愿。更不用说在这些采访中，这些人从未被充分告知他们的权利或被允许有律师。
The fight over whether to suppress these statements has been going on, you will be shocked to learn, for many years in many different forms. The week we were there, the excitement was that former FBI agent Frank Pellegrino was going to be testifying, the agent who took a clean statement from Khalid Sheikh Mohammed at Guantanamo. He'd been after KSM for years prior to September 11th, probably knew more about him than anyone in law enforcement.
关于是否压制这些陈述的斗争，你会惊讶地发现，已经在许多年里以多种不同形式持续进行了。我们在那里的那周，激动人心的是前联邦调查局探员弗兰克·佩莱格里诺将要作证，他是那个在关塔那摩从哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德那里获得清洁陈述的探员。在9月11日之前，他已经追查KSM多年，可能比任何执法人员都更了解他。
Pellegrino's testimony seemed great for the prosecution. He came across as credible, said KSM answered his questions voluntarily, that he even cracked a joke or two. But Pellegrino also seemed restive with anger at the position the CIA had put him and other FBI agents in because of the black sites and the torture.
佩莱格里诺的证词对检方似乎很有利。他表现得很可信，说KSM是自愿回答他的问题的，甚至还开了一两个玩笑。但佩莱格里诺似乎也对中情局因秘密监狱和酷刑而将他和其他联邦调查局探员置于的处境感到愤怒。
Under questioning, Pellegrino said, quote, "I think that the whole thing from the beginning was a flaming bag of crap that we got stuck with," unquote. One defense attorney told me it was the first time a witness had said something so plainly critical of the torture program since the proceedings began a dozen years ago.
在审讯中，佩莱格里诺说，引用原话：“我认为从一开始，整件事就是我们被迫接受的一袋着火的狗屎。”一位辩护律师告诉我，这是自十二年前程序开始以来，第一次有证人如此直白地批评酷刑计划。
A couple other significant things had happened, too-- hugely significant. The week before, the judge had severed Ramzi bin al-Shibh from the 9/11 case, deciding, after about a decade of litigation, that he was mentally incompetent to aid in his own defense. Ramzi bin al-Shibh is generally considered the second most culpable of the five defendants, sort of like KSM's deputy.
还有两件重大的事情发生了——非常重大。前一周，法官将拉姆齐·比纳勒什布从“9·11”案中剔除，决定在经过大约十年的诉讼后，他在精神上无力协助自己的辩护。拉姆齐·比纳勒什布通常被认为是五名被告中罪责第二大的，有点像KSM的副手。
The other major news was that a month earlier, a judge in the other death penalty case before the military commissions against the Saudi man accused of orchestrating the deadly bombing of the USS Cole in 2000, that judge threw out the clean team statements in the Cole case, saying they were tainted by torture. These developments seemed to me to point in the direction of plea deals. The 9/11 case seemed like it was disintegrating.
另一个主要新闻是，一个月前，军事委员会审理的另一起死刑案（针对一名被指控策划2000年对“科尔”号驱逐舰致命爆炸案的沙特男子）的法官驳回了“科尔”案中的“清洁团队陈述”，称它们受到酷刑的污染。这些事态发展在我看来都指向认罪协议的方向。这个“9·11”案件似乎正在瓦解。
I'd come down to Guantánamo thinking the plea deals were dead. But everyone was saying they're not. Really, they're not. We just have to find a different way to get them done. J. Connell told reporters, the plea deals are sleeping. Not in a coma-- sleeping.
我来到关塔那摩时以为认罪协议已经死了。但每个人都说没有。真的没有。我们只是必须找到不同的方式来完成它们。J.康奈尔告诉记者，认罪协议正在休眠。不是昏迷——只是休眠。
Right now, the feels like temperature, which I think is accurate, is 98 degrees.
现在，体感温度，我认为是准确的，是98华氏度。
Most evenings, a bunch of us reporters hang out on outdoor couches in the hotel's courtyard. Contract workers often sit at the tables nearby, everybody drinking, while the leggy stray cats of Guantánamo dart around the edges of the patio. Colleen came to join us a couple of times to talk about the case and also to reminisce. She's known most of these reporters for years. A few of them were on a flight to Guantánamo so notoriously terrifying that people still talk about it.
大多数晚上，我们一群记者在酒店院子里的户外沙发上消磨时光。合同工通常坐在附近的桌子旁，大家喝着酒，而关塔那摩那长腿的流浪猫在露台边缘飞奔。科琳来过几次加入我们，谈论案件，也回忆过去。她认识这些记者中的大多数人多年了。其中几个人曾在一次极其恐怖的飞往关塔那摩的航班上，人们至今谈论着它。
I had taken a lot of Ativan, and I went and sat next to you and said-- I'm like, tell me everything you know about Khalid Sheikh Mohammed. And I took, like, three sentences of notes, and then I trailed off, I guess. I don't know. [LAUGHS]
我服用了大量的安定，我走过去坐在你旁边说——我说，把你知道关于哈立德·谢赫·穆罕默德的一切都告诉我。我做了大约三句笔记，然后我就不知所云了，我想。我不知道。（笑）
What year was that?
那是哪一年？
I'm not a war reporter, but I imagine this is sort of what it's like after hours, minus the danger-- people thrown together, trying to make sense of a protracted battle. The so-called war on terror has been enormous, global, and yet, sitting here, it can feel like the whole thing is funneled down to this small klatch of people-- reporters, victims, attorneys, soldiers, drinking in the courtyard of the Navy Gateway Inn and Suites.
我不是战地记者，但我想像一下，这就是下班后的样子，除了没有危险——人们被迫聚在一起，试图理清一场旷日持久的战争。所谓的反恐战争规模巨大、全球化，然而，坐在这里，感觉整个事情被压缩到了这一小群人身上——记者、受害者、律师、士兵，在海军招待所和套房的院子里喝酒。
We start talking about how this case ends. Plea deals, John Ryan from LawDragon says. 100%. Terry McDermott, who co-wrote The Hunt for KSM, agrees-- there's never going to be a trial. Carol Rosenberg of The New York Times thinks maybe an abatement could happen. That at some point, the judge might say, OK, government, if you won't produce CIA witnesses, then I'm going to pull the plug. Everybody go home until you're ready to make this a fair trial, which could mean no resolution at all.
我们开始谈论这个案件如何结束。来自LawDragon的约翰·瑞安说，认罪协议。100%。共同撰写了《追捕KSM》的特里·麦克德莫特表示同意——永远不会有审判。《纽约时报》的卡罗尔·罗森伯格认为也许会发生中止。在某种程度上，法官可能会说，好吧，政府，如果你不传唤中情局证人，那我就拔掉插头。在你们准备好进行公平审判之前，大家回家吧，这可能意味着根本没有解决方案。
One night, J. Connell, the defense attorney, turns up. He's wearing shorts and sandals, a brace on his ankle from an injury sustained in spin class. He grabs a club soda. I ask him, all these things that are happening-- the decision to sever Ramzi bin al-Shibh, the USS Cole judge's ruling on the clean team statements, the flaming pile of crap-- does it feel like this case might be crumbling in the defense's favor? He says, look, I know you've been down here before.
一天晚上，辩护律师J.康奈尔出现了。他穿着短裤和凉鞋，脚踝上带着因动感单车课受伤而戴的护具。他拿了一瓶苏打水。我问他，所有这些正在发生的事情——剔除拉姆齐·比纳勒什布的决定，“科尔”号案法官关于清洁团队陈述的裁决，那袋着火的狗屎——感觉这个案件是否正在向辩方有利的方向崩溃？他说，看，我知道你以前来过这里。
And there's this temptation to feel like I've come at a pivotal moment, and something important is happening. But this is our 47th hearing? And they've all felt like that. Like, I always feel like if it were a boxing match, we'd have won every round on points. But what does that matter? There's no tallying up of points. There's no points. And so, we'll come back in November, and then we'll come back again in February, and we'll come back and back and back and back.
人们总有一种诱惑，觉得我是在关键时刻来的，有什么重要的事情正在发生。但这是我们的第47次听证会？它们听起来都像这样。就像，我总是觉得如果这是一场拳击赛，我们本来会在点数上赢每一轮。但这有什么关系？没有点数汇总。没有点数。所以，我们将会在11月回来，然后我们在2月回来，我们将回来，回来，回来，回来。
J.'s been on this case full-time since 2011. J. believes in the rightness of his mission, that the US government's power cannot go unchecked or trample human rights. He tries not to get caught up in what should happen or could happen. He says he's going to stick with this case as long as it takes.
J.自2011年以来全职从事此案。J.相信他使命的正确性，即美国政府的权力不能不受制约或践踏人权。他尽量不被应该发生或可能发生的事情所困扰。他说他会一直坚持这个案件，无论需要多久。
But for a minute there, he really thought this thing might end, that the plea deals would materialize, maybe by the end of 2022. He started planning his next move, entertainment law. He wants to work in the music industry. He even ordered slick new business cards, the kind that feel like a credit card.
但有一分钟，他真的认为这件事可能会结束，认罪协议可能会实现，也许在2022年底之前。他开始计划他的下一步行动，娱乐法。他想在音乐行业工作。他甚至订购了时尚的新名片，那种感觉像信用卡的名片。
Do you ever get the sense that the prosecution feels exactly the same way you guys do on the defense side? That everyone is just like, we're locked in this falling apart train that just keeps going?
你是否偶尔会有种感觉，检方在感觉上和你们辩方一模一样？每个人都像是，我们被锁在这辆分崩离析的火车上，它还在继续前行？
In dark moments, I feel like I'm a puppet in a revenge fantasy where somebody, 15 years ago, decided that they were going to put on this show about getting the death penalty against these men, knowing that the military doesn't really execute people. Military hasn't executed anyone since 1961, and that they needed actors for their-- they needed to put people in place. They needed to put defense attorneys in place, prosecutors in place, judge in place.
在黑暗的时刻，我觉得自己就像是一个复仇幻想中的傀儡，有人在15年前决定，他们要上演这出关于对这些人处以死刑的戏，明知军队并不真正处决人。军队自1961年以来就没有处决过任何人，而且他们需要演员来出演他们的——他们需要把人安置到位。他们需要安置辩护律师，安置检察官，安置法官。
I don't always feel that way, but sometimes it feels like that. And I could entirely imagine that the prosecution would feel like that. That they are put up there to represent the forces of revenge, and that we're put up there to represent the forces of the rule of law, and that there's just kind of a play that happens.
我并不总是那样感觉，但有时确实感觉像那样。我可以完全想象检方也会有这种感觉。他们被放在那里代表复仇力量，而我们被放在那里代表法治力量，这只是一场发生在那里的戏。
The prosecutors weren't permitted to discuss the case with me on the record, so I can't say whether they share J's revenge fantasy feeling. But the prosecution were the ones who initiated the plea negotiations two years ago, as the road to trial was getting only longer and darker. They want this show over, too.
检察官不允许与我记录在案地讨论这个案件，所以我无法说他们是否分享了J.的那种复仇幻想感。但检方是在两年前发起认罪谈判的人，因为通往审判的道路变得越来越长、越来越黑。他们也想让这场戏结束。
Toward the end of the week, I checked in with Colleen one last time. She'd been up since 3:00 AM, she said. Her mind had been churning, so she said she wrote it all down to get her thoughts outside her body. She'd underestimated how sad this trip was for her.
那周快结束时，我最后一次与科琳沟通。她说她从凌晨3点就醒了。她的脑子一直在转，所以她说她把一切都写了下来，让她的思想走出体外。她低估了这次旅行对她来说是多么悲伤。
I never cry down here. I mean, like, yeah, this was like the third time I cried down here. I don't usually cry down here. And I'm not saying that's like good or bad. It just is what it is. It was just, this trip was really emotional.
我从不在这里哭。我是说，是的，这是我第三次在这里哭。我通常不在这里哭。我不是说这是好事还是坏事。这只是事实而已。这次旅行真的很感人。
I'd seen some of that earlier in the week. Within 24 hours of our arrival, I'd gone to find her in her hotel room a couple of floors below mine. She was falling apart a little, missing her brother, worried she couldn't remember his voice anymore, and also just being down here again, watching this case rattle back to life.
我之前在那周早些时候看到过一些迹象。我们抵达后不到24小时，我就去楼下她的酒店房间找她。她有点崩溃了，想念她的哥哥，担心自己记不起他的声音了，也只是因为再次来到这里，看着这个案件蹒跚回到生命中。
I think I've pinned a lot of my hope for accountability and getting to the bottom of this on some kind of a legal process because it just feels like, Jesus, he was murdered. Somebody be responsible for that.
我想我已经把很多关于问责和弄清真相的希望都寄托在某种法律程序上了，因为它感觉就像，上帝啊，他被谋杀了。有人要为此负责。
This side of Colleen, I wasn't familiar with. I'd seen only confident, rigorous, determined Colleen, but never Colleen in despair.
科琳的这一面，我不太熟悉。我只见过自信、严谨、坚定的科琳，却从未见过处于绝望中的科琳。
I feel like I've said this 20,000 times, but I'm really feeling this now. I don't know that there's ever-- that this is ever going to happen. I don't know that there will ever be a trial. I've never felt-- I've never questioned it as strongly as I am now. [SIGHS]
我觉得我已经说过这句话2万次了，但我现在真的有这种感觉。我不知道是否曾经——这是否会发生。我不知道是否会有审判。我从未——我从未像现在这样强烈地质疑它。（叹气）
Waiting 20 years for a trial doesn't just deny Colleen answers. Year after year after year, it prolongs her grief, makes dealing with her brother's death harder-- if such a thing is possible.
等待20年进行一场审判，不仅剥夺了科琳的答案。年复一年，它延长了她的悲伤，使处理她哥哥的去世变得更加困难——如果那种事情是有可能的。
By the end of the week, Colleen was more collected. She told me the VFMs had met with the defense the night before. She cried a lot at that meeting, too, she said. Like J. Connell, she knows better than to get her hopes up, but she realized she'd gotten her hopes up about a plea deal.
到那周结束时，科琳冷静了一些。她告诉我VFM前一天晚上与辩方见了面。她说她在那个会议上也哭得很厉害。像J.康奈尔一样，她知道不要抱太大希望，但她意识到她确实对认罪协议抱有希望。
The lawyers had talked about how close they'd come, really kind of close to a deal. In the meeting, Colleen had aired her most cynical and, she worries, possibly her most realistic analysis of how this all ends, which is nothing. No trial, no plea deal, no ending.
律师们谈到了他们有多接近，真的很接近达成协议。在会议上，科琳发表了她最愤世嫉俗的，她担心这可能是她对这一切如何结束的最现实的分析，那就是什么都没有。没有审判，没有认罪协议，没有结束。
And that that nothingness, that is the plan, a plan that would serve the interests of some powerful stakeholders, namely the CIA, which would never have to reveal the identities of the people who conducted and enabled torture, or the countries where it all happened.
那种虚无，那就是计划，一个服务于一些强大利益相关者（即中情局）利益的计划，他们将永远不必揭露那些实施和促成酷刑的人的身份，或发生这一切的国家。
Also, the detainees, who could quietly stay here at Guantánamo in the communal confinement they want, presumed innocent until they die, forgotten. The politicians who could keep kicking this toxic can farther and farther into the distance, keep pretending it's out of their hands. Who this plan doesn't serve, of course, is Colleen.
还有，那些被拘留者，他们可以安静地留在这里，留在他们想要的关塔那摩的公共监禁中，在他们死前被推定无罪，被遗忘。那些政客可以继续把这个有毒的罐头踢得越来越远，继续假装这超出了他们的控制。当然，这个计划不服务的人，是科琳。
A postscript and perhaps an antidote to this dolorous trip-- while we were at Guantánamo, another Peaceful Tomorrows member was there, too-- Leila Murphy. Her week was so different from Colleen's. She was so different from Colleen. In the past few years, as founding members of Peaceful Tomorrows have grown infirm or died, a bunch of young people have joined. They're children of 9/11 victims-- Leila and her sister Jessica, Liz, Aiden. A young woman named Chanel started coming to the Zoom meetings in November.
关于这次悲伤旅行的附录，也许是一种解药——我们在关塔那摩时，另一位“和平明天”成员也在那里——莱拉·墨菲。她的一周与科琳的完全不同。她与科琳非常不同。在过去几年里，“和平明天”的创始成员逐渐衰弱或去世，一群年轻人加入了。他们是“9·11”遇难者的子女——莱拉和她的妹妹杰西卡、利兹、艾登。一个叫香奈儿的年轻女子在11月开始参加Zoom会议。
Obviously, they're self-selecting, but a remarkable number of these 9/11 kids have studied Arabic and the Middle East or spent time there. Leila's becoming a lawyer. She wants to do criminal defense. Her sister's in med school. She's interested in the effects of torture on human health. The Murphy sisters have joked darkly that this was KSM's plan all along-- to radicalize the children of 9/11 victims against their own government.
显然，他们是自愿选择的，但这些“9·11”孩子中有相当多的人学习了阿拉伯语和中东研究，或者在那里度过了一段时间。莱拉正在成为一名律师。她想做刑事辩护。她的妹妹正在医学院学习。她对酷刑对人类健康的影响感兴趣。墨菲姐妹阴郁地开玩笑说，这才是KSM一直以来的计划——使“9·11”受害者的子女激进化，反对他们自己的政府。
During the day at Guantánamo, Leila met with attorneys, took copious notes during court. She was with two other young people, one a fellow law student, another a recently minted lawyer. In the evenings, they did what young people do-- played cornhole at the Tiki Bar, played tennis or pickleball.
在关塔那摩的日子里，莱拉会见律师，在法庭上做了大量笔记。她与另外两名年轻人在一起，一个是法学院学生，另一个是刚入行的律师。晚上，他们做年轻人该做的事——在Tiki吧玩沙包投掷游戏，打网球或匹克球。
Also, I just love the sign-- "First dedicated pickleball courts in the Navy."
还有，我喜欢那个标志——“海军第一个专用匹克球场”。
Wait, actually?
等等，真的吗？
That's what it says on the sign with, like, pickle clip art. [LAUGHS]
标志上是这么写的，还有匹克球的剪贴画。（笑）
It's not that Leila was living it up. It's that she seemed to have no expectations from this trip. She was an observer in the literal sense, taking it in, noting it down.
并不是说莱拉过得很奢华。而是她似乎对这次旅行没有任何期望。她是一个字面意义上的观察者，接受这一切，记录下来。
She admires Colleen and Terry and the other members of this group, but she doesn't need what they need. She's not waiting for answers from the 9/11 accused. She doesn't need a trial. And sure, a plea deal would be good. She'll lobby for that.
她钦佩科琳、特里和该团体的其他成员，但她不需要他们需要的东西。她并不在等待“9·11”被告的答案。她不需要审判。当然，认罪协议会很好。她会为此游说。
But whatever happens to these five aging defendants, she doubts it'll have meaning for her. What Leila wants, what would be most meaningful to her, is an admission of guilt from the US government.
但无论这五名年迈的被告发生什么，她怀疑这对她是否会有意义。莱拉想要的是，对她最有意义的是，美国政府承认有罪。
Their horrible behavior is the reason we're in this situation and the reason it's dragging on for so long and the reason that they're even pleased. Like, there will never be any real justice, you know, because it's just all so fucked up. [LAUGHS] The US's behavior is the reason this has dragged on.
他们可怕的行为是我们处于这种情况的原因，也是它拖延这么久的原因，也是他们甚至在商讨认罪协议的原因。就像，永远不会有真正的正义，你知道，因为这一切都太操蛋了。（笑）美国的行为是这件事拖延的原因。
Leila's voice dropped. A guy in military uniform was walking past, close enough to hear us.
莱拉的声音低了下来。一个穿着军装的男人正走过，离我们足够近，能听到我们的谈话。
Did you just get nervous because you saw someone who looked like military?
你刚才是不是因为看到看起来像军人的人而感到紧张了？
Yes, I did. It's classic Guantánamo.
是的，我是。这是典型的关塔那摩现象。
I understood her trepidation. It feels somehow heretical, or at least ungrateful, with all these soldiers and sailors around, for Leila to say, all the government's post 9/11 effort, the endless war and the prison and the court, I know you did it for me. You did it in my name. But none of it worked. So it's time to stop now. Just say you made a huge mistake and that you're sorry.
我理解她的恐惧。对于莱拉来说，当有这么多士兵和水手在场时，说出“所有政府在9/11之后的努力，无休止的战争、监狱和法庭，我知道你们是为了我才做的。你们是以我的名义做的。但这一切都没用。所以现在该停止了。承认你们犯了一个大错，并且你们很抱歉。”感觉就像是异端，或者至少是忘恩负义。
Leila knows it's a long shot. She was three years old when her father died in 2001. And in all the time since, the government has never held itself accountable, has never worked to reset our common morality as a country. But this young person who's about to become a lawyer, it'd be so great if she could have this little bit of hope in the forces of the rule of law.
莱拉知道这很难。2001年她父亲去世时她才三岁。从那时起，政府从未追究自己的责任，也从未努力重塑我们作为一个国家的共同道德观。但这个即将成为律师的年轻人，如果她能对法治力量抱有这一点点希望，那该多好。
Sarah Koenig.
萨拉·凯尼格。
This episode, from season 4 of Serial, was produced by Jessica Weisberg and edited by Julie Snyder, Dana Chivvis, Jen Guerra, and myself, with Rozina Ali, John Ryan, and Carol Rosenberg. Additional reporting from Cora Currier and Emma Grillo. Fact-checking by Kelsey Kudak and Ben Phelan. The original score was composed by Sofia Degli Alessandri. Music supervision, sound design, and mixing by Phoebe Wang.
本集来自《Serial》第四季，由杰西卡·韦斯伯格制作，朱莉·斯奈德、达娜·奇维斯、简·格拉和我本人编辑，罗齐娜·阿里、约翰·瑞安和卡罗尔·罗森伯格协助。额外报道来自科拉·柯里尔和艾玛·格里洛。事实核查由凯尔西·库达克和本·费兰完成。原创配乐由索菲亚·德利·亚历山德里作曲。音乐监督、声音设计和混音由菲比·王完成。
The series is produced by Serial Productions and the New York Times. You can hear the rest of the season-- and I recommend it-- wherever you get your podcasts. Diane Wu, Mike Comite, Safiyah Riddle, and Matt Tierney helped put together this episode of our show. Special thanks to Al-Amyn Sumar, Susan Wessling, Ndeye Thioubou, Mack Miller, Nina Lassam, and New York Times Deputy Managing Editor Sam Dolnick.
该系列由Serial Productions和《纽约时报》联合制作。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听本季剩余节目——我推荐收听。黛安·吴、迈克·科米特、萨菲亚·里德尔和马特·蒂尔尼协助制作了本集节目。特别感谢Al-Amyn Sumar、苏珊·韦斯林、Ndeye Thioubou、马克·米勒、尼娜·拉萨姆和《纽约时报》副总编辑萨姆·多尼克。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He told me that growing up, his family had not one, not two, but three wells in the backyard. I was like, really?
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他告诉我，他成长过程中，他们家后院不只有一口井，不是两口，而是三口。我说，真的吗？
(SUBJECT) VICTIM FAMILY MEMBER: Well, well, well, yeah.
嗯，嗯，嗯，是的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。